c'est un système tentaculaire Wagner
au-delà de la partie sécurité qu'on
connaît tous la partie militarisée qu'on
connaît tous il y a toute une espèce
d'inébuleuse qui est gérée par Concorde
que la holding qui était à
Saint-Pétersbourg et donc il les
activités de d'influence qui sont
extrêmement importantes puis les
activités économiques sont également
extrêmement importantes puisque vous
avez une espèce de main mise d'une
partie des gens de Warner en tout cas
c'est pas Wagner c'est Concorde on va
dire plutôt ça comme ça et qu'il y a une
activité extrêmement importante en
Afrique dans le domaine des matières
premières des ressources naturelles donc
ils ont des participations dans tous les
pays qui se négocié pays par pays et
métiers par métier par métier ce qui
veut dire qu'en fait vous avez une
holding qui est à Saint-Pétersbourg qui
s'appelle Concorde vous avez un Wagner
qui est l'outil militarisé qui n'existe
pas parce qu'il y a pas de statut de
Wagner puis vous avez une nébuleuse de
société entre autres qui vont gérer je
dirais le trésor de guerre donc les les
participations dans les mines d'or les
mines de manganèse le cuivre le tourisme
le transport et tout une série
d'activités dans lequel en fait Concorde
trigogine a pris des parts de marché ça
c'est la fameuse galaxie galaxie
pregojin ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
qu'aujourd'hui remettre la main votre
Viber c'est remettre la main certes sur
des milliers de mercenaires mais c'est
également beaucoup d'argent beaucoup de
sociétés alors c'est presque impossible
en fait de reprendre la main là-dessus
pourquoi parce que c'est le domaine du
privé c'est le domaine de l'entreprise
dès lors que vous avez des
participations vous avez une société qui
s'appelle lobbying veste qui est basé en
RCA elle travaille dans le domaine du
diamant et les participations locales
des Chinois vous avez des Malgaches vous
avez toutes des séries de donc ce sont
des vraies sociétés donc l'État russe ne
peut pas préempter cette richesse ils
peuvent prianter simplement le trésor de
guerre de trigogie lui-même et j'imagine
que Prigogine dans ses activités là on
le voit pas apparaître directement il y
a toute une série ce qu'on appelle des
nominés ou des proxy donc des systèmes
qui permet en fait d'être invisibles
donc vous avez une nébuleuse un biotope
extrêmement important qui capte des des
des
millions alors des milliards je connais
pas les chiffres exacts mais en tout cas
les tarifs ne peut pas préempter cette
activité qui est une activité économique
privée dans quelle mesure est-ce qu'il
va tenter malgré tout de remettre la
main sur les activités de trigogine
alors ce qui va essayer de faire un
premier temps c'est ce qui essaie de
depuis le mois de juillet cette année
mais depuis le mois de juin en fait de
récupérer l'outil militaire qui était
vraiment l'outil qui est qui avait
complètement dépassé les limites
puisqu'en fait l'outil militaire ils
sont allés jusqu'à globalement 50000
hommes ce qui est un chiffre absolument
énorme le dernier chiffre que j'ai eu
qui était sur la chaîne télégramme de
Wagner c'était qu'il y avait en
Biélorussie et 7500 combattants de
Wagner en Afrique il avait 15000 en
Russie il avait 10000 qui se préparait
qui se formaient qui se reposaient et
puis il y avait deux 3000 qui se
promenaient à gauche à droite pour
renforcer etc donc en fait on était sur
une base de 35000 hommes ça c'était les
chiffres de début de tout début août ce
qui veut dire que c'était après la
décision du ministère de la Défense
d'obliger les SMP entre autres Wagner de
signer des contrats avec avec l'armée
donc avec l'Etat russe donc le diable
sur un modèle déjà de régression 35000
c'est un chiffre absolument considérable
et depuis les choses ont changé il y a
eu donc la mort de Prigogine le 23 août
que vont devenir les mercenaires
certains ont déjà été intégrés à l'armée
russe c'est ça alors on peut diviser en
trois paquets un premier paquet je
dirais un bon tiers qui est déjà parti
ou en tout cas qui sert qui renforcent
l'armée russe l'armée russe a besoin des
combattants de Wagner pourquoi parce que
abaquemouth pendant 6 mois ils sont
battus ils ont ils ont conquis backmouth
indéniablement donc cette expérience je
dirais du combat cette expérience du
combat avec des Ukrainiens vraiment un
combat de fantassin combat corps à corps
extrêmement difficile donc l'armée russe
a besoin de ces cadres là pour les
recycler dans son armée qui est une
armée de conscrit donc ils ont besoin
d'avoir ces cadres là ont-ils à
rejoindre l'armée russe alors je dirais
le prestige de les galons parce que
souvent vous avez des gens qui sont
officiers ou sont des capots des capots
chefs à ce niveau là on va aller faire
demi-heure lieutenant capitaine assez
rapidement donc ils vont rentrer dans un
système administratif qui peut convenir
et quelqu'un qui avait envie de faire
une carrière mais ça concerne on leur a
réservé un plutôt bon accueil bah oui
parce qu'ils sont les combattants
d'autant que vous savez Wagner il y a
toujours une espèce de consanguinité
extrêmement forte entre Wagner le
système Wagner et les tarus à l'origine
quand ils ont créé Wagner en 2013 le
ceux qui sont penchés sur le berceau
c'était le FSB le la rue l'armée la
garde nationale donc si vous voulez il y
a toujours une consanguinité il y a
toujours une espèce de comment dire de
proximité évident si vous voulez de
capillarité pourrait-on dire entre
Wagner et le système russe donc ça ça
s'est jamais arrêté quelque part
simplement à un moment donné comment
dire privilégier en investissant
personnellement son argent puisqu'il a
investi 125 millions de dollars
lorsqu'il a créé Wagner en 2013 donc il
est devenu propriétaire d'un outil qui
appartient en fait structurellement à
l'état à l'origine alors vous disiez il
y a il y a trois parties il y a donc
ceux qui ont rejoint les rangs de
l'armée russe quels sont les autres tu
en as notamment qui sont très amères
contre le pouvoir russe après la mort de
priscogène alors moi je crois que c'est
une minorité parce qu'en fait ils sont
un peu désœuvrés et c'est vrai que
trigogine on l'oublie il avait un
prestige incroyable pourquoi c'est la
seule autorité russe qui était sur le
fond pendant 6 mois probablement que
pris goji était le seul je dirais
encadrant russe parce que c'est
difficile de dire officier ou général
c'est pas le cas mais il connaissait
parfaitement la situation de l'armée
russe il connaissait parfaitement la
situation du sur le terrain donc et donc
quand il agressé rappelez-vous
verbalement dans ces dans la
communication je dirais télévisée hyper
agressif pourquoi ce qu'il savait
exactement ce qui se passait les
milliers de morts le manque de munitions
le manque de transport la non évacuation
des blessés on abandonné les morts sur
place etc donc il a réagi et ça c'est le
dernier précise incroyable d'autant que
rappelez-vous il a créé toute une série
de cimetières dans lequel on enterrer
les gens de Wagner donc les morts
étaient respectés et des rappelez
également un point très intéressant
c'est qu'on voit que depuis quelques
semaines les targues est en train de
raser tous les cimetières que Prigogine
avait mis en oeuvre dans lequel les gens
de Wagner étaient enterrés ce que vous
dites c'est qu'au sein de Wagner Laura
delgami prigogne est totalement intact
il est énorme d'autant que encore une
fois il en reste un tierce que un tiers
sont partis dans l'armée russe un tiers
ont quitté sont rentrés chez eux tout
simplement faire autre chose et puis un
tiers est resté donc si vous avez 50 000
hommes il en reste à peu près 20 000 qui
sont encore des plus rayures de Wagner
mais Wagner c'est pas fini c'est pas
parce que c'est pas parce que
concrètement pris goji n'est mort que
que le système n'a pas fonctionné
pourquoi parce qu'en fait Prigogine a
désigné un dauphin
le dauphin s'appelle
Elisa Rohff antonellizarroff alors j'ai
du mal à rareté son oncle qui est
quelqu'un un vrai combattant qu'un
ancien des forces spéciales qui a
rejoint Wagner en comment dire en
2015 ou 2016 en Syrie ça combattant et
c'est lui aujourd'hui qui est le comment
dire le reste de Wagner donc aujourd'hui
Wagner n'est pas mort les activités de
Wagner en Afrique sont gérés par les
arafes comment va se décider justement
cette succession après gaugine vous vous
dise vous dites pardon c'est cet homme
qui va qui va reprendre les activités
alors
vagin n'existe pas c'est pas une entité
comme une société donc en fait c'est une
espèce de c'est une bande c'est une
structure si vous voulez un peu
informelle dans lequel vous avez une
espèce de commandement par la violence
par la force un système assez mafieux
mais est-ce que ça ça peut tenir dans le
temps ça oui parce qu'en fait le
problème c'est tout dépend si les tarifs
veulent les laisser parce que tout
dépend du niveau d'acte des légendes que
va faire le Wagner d'aujourd'hui le
nouveau Wagner le New Wagner par rapport
à l'Etat russe pourquoi il y a un
avantage de Wagner parce que Wagner
aujourd'hui on voit bien que si un
offensive une croûte enfantine russe
c'est pas impensable que si le front se
stabilise avec les Ukrainiens que les
que les Russes lancent une conte
offensive dans le Nord quel est le
discours de lizaraf aujourd'hui de
Wagner c'est de dire laissez-nous faire
le boulot qu'on a fait à Mahmoud et
savait économiser les conscrits on voit
bien que l'armée russe a un problème
avec les conscrits ils veulent pas si
vous voulez des décider une espèce de
mobilisation générale eux ce qu'ils
veulent c'est au coup par coup envoyé
par tranche de 100000 hommes c'est vrai
que Wagner les morts de Wagner elle
n'était pas comptabilisés dans les morts
russes c'était des combattants un peu
mystérieux si vous voulez mais ils
étaient pas donc ça concerne pas les
mamans ça concerne pas les papas ça
concerne pas les familles russes et
c'est vrai le rôle de Wagner le fait
d'être dans une ce qu'on appelle une
empreinte minimum c'est un rôle
extrêmement important donc encore une
fois le rôle de Wagner des parents qui
va s'éteindre dès lors que la guerre
continue quelles sont les relations
entre entre cet homme désigné par par
Prigogine et les arafes et Vladimir
Poutine alors je pense pas qu'il y en
ait beaucoup parce que là on a un vrai
combattant parce que c'est lui qui a
pris Solidar par exemple donc sur le
dard c'est juste avant bac mood donc
c'est à peu près 7 8 mois donc encore
une fois c'est un vrai combattant donc
je pense que quelqu'un comme Poutine
peut se contenter d'avoir un combat un
ex fera un combattant pour faire court
plutôt discipliné et plutôt organiser
parce que l'outil Wagner c'est entre
guillemets c'est un bon outil encore une
fois on est bien d'accord que c'est un
outil qui est considéré comme terroriste
c'est un outil comme d'une violence
extrême si vous voulez ou les droits de
l'homme n'existe pas l'histoire de la
masse et cetera encore une fois je juge
pas l'aspect droit de l'homme gouverne
par la violence avec oui c'est un signe
du violon c'est inouï c'est incroyable
mais on préfère c'est la guerre c'est
une guerre absolument atroce vous savez
la guerre des fantassins qui a
actuellement c'est c'est les gens des
gens de 20 ans qui agonisent dans les
tranchées etc donc c'est une guerre
absolument monstrueuse donc s'il le bien
le mal est extrêmement difficile à
discerner et moi je pense que
aujourd'hui la Russie a clairement
besoin de ce genre de structure elle
peut pas s'en passer puisque l'outil
existe donc ils vont l'utiliser Moscou
ne peut pas se passer de Wagner
aujourd'hui oui oui ou Wagner ou quelque
chose qui ressemble à ça c'est pour ça
qu'on assiste aujourd'hui depuis
quelques depuis à peu près un an ou deux
un espèce de développement des scmpus
c'est à peu près une trentaine donc tous
les domaines gaz prend aujourd'hui
développe ses propres sociétés financer
ses propres sociétés alors pour protéger
les installations pétrolière par exemple
mais pour essayer d'autres activités on
voit un exemple que Shogun le Misa
défense a créé lui-même qu'on ne voyait
patriote patriote qui est sa propre SMP
si vous voulez pour concurrencer
directement Wagner donc on assiste
depuis quelques semaines si vous voulez
quelques mois à une montée en puissance
de ces groupes armés de ces structures
je dirais assez disciplinés mais
extrêmement armé mais qui est capable
d'être utilisé sur le terrain ce que je
veux dire c'est que tant que la guerre
en Ukraine va durer la Russie ne peut
pas se passer de CSMP société médicale
privée est-ce que Wagner on va parler
des autres sociétés militaires privées
bien sûr mais sur Wagner est-ce que
l'organisation dispose aujourd'hui
d'autant de moyens que ceux dont qu'elle
avait il y a encore quelques mois alors
oui les encore même si elle a rendu pas
mal de munitions et d'armement à l'armée
parce que l'armée a considéré au mois de
juillet l'armée a dit fin juillet il y a
eu un rapport qui est sorti comme quoi
Wagner avait rendu 20000 tonnes de
matériel donc c'est des quantités
colossales de d'armement de munitions
donc concrètement une partie de Wagner
on va venir a joué le jeu ça c'est le
premier point le deuxième point si vous
voulez c'est que l'outil va être bien
sûr réutilisé par la force par la force
des choses je connais pas l'avenir le
problème de Wagner c'est l'entité
c'était quand même pris d'origine
c'était que le charisme était à la tête
du système dès lors qu'il a disparu
comment il va gérer les arroches je sais
pas comment il va gérer il va gérer mais
il va que gérer il va pas animer il va
pas construire et de toute façon et les
arafes n'a pas les moyens aujourd'hui de
gérer la partie influence et la partie
économique il peut gérer que la partie
militaire donc on voit bien qu'il y a
une espèce de déshérence sur la partie
sur les usines atrol sur le sur la
partie économique sur toute la partie
qui concerne l'or concerne le pétrole le
gaz etc ça c'est un autre sujet pourquoi
parce que on sait des structures je veux
dire sur les sociétés officielles ça
donc on peut pas jouer avec encore une
fois et les erreurs n'a pas la qualité
n'a pas la spécificité n'a pas le métier
pour gérer ça il va essayer de garder si
vous voulez un vaguenerbis mais Wagner
va être noyé avec d'autres sociétés dans
la trentaine des CMP qui est en train de
monter en puissance ils seront dans le
dans le magma ils auront des missions
ils ont un soutien de l'État mais ils
seront totalement je dirais subordonnés
à l'armée russe certaines autres
sociétés militaires privées qui comme
vous l'avez dit pull en Russie
actuellement sont-elles en mesure et
bien de reprendre un certain nombre des
activités de Wagner notamment les
activités sur le plan économique alors
pas tout à fait directement parce que
encore une fois le problème c'est que à
quoi servent ces sociétés là on voit
bien Gazprom a besoin d'avoir des SMS
pourquoi pour protéger ses installations
pétrolières on voit bien que que les
gouverneurs de province ont besoin de
SMP pourquoi parce qu'on est un peu dans
le règne sous les de ce qu'on appelle
les seigneurs de la guerre donc c'est
vrai que c'est important d'avoir les
sociétés qui protègent le système parce
que c'est comme c'est un monde un peu
c'est un monde mafieux quelque part donc
ils ont besoin d'avoir un cirque qui les
protège donc je pense pas qu'aujourd'hui
il est velléité pour remplacer Wagner ex
ni l'eau en Afrique par exemple sauf
s'il y a deux trois sociétés comme Siwa
sécurisé ou Morane qui sont d'ores et
déjà en Afrique vous savez à l'origine
en 2018 quand ils ont monté Wagner les
montants puissances en RCA réduction
africaine c'est pas Wagner qui est qui a
été en premier la boîte s'appelait c'est
où est-ce que des services triple s donc
on voit bien que vous avez cette
nébuleuse qui préexiste qui existent
toujours et qui est extrêmement active
encore il suffit de l'animer tout
simplement donc Wagner n'était
simplement qu'une excroissance d'un
système qui se développait assez général
sachant que Wagner lui-même avait été
créé sur les les comment dire sur les
débris d'une société qui s'appelait
slavonique Corporation et outkine était
lui-même à des directeurs de slavoniques
donc on voit bien qu'il y a une espèce
de darbrication entre les MP entre le
pouvoir entre les flux d'argent et entre
l'activité et les activités économiques
les activités militaires donc c'est très
compliqué et ça ça peut pas se déliter
en 3 minutes ça ça se déconstruit mais
progressivement éventuellement est-ce
que malgré tout l'aventure entre
guillemets de prix goji dans la tête de
Wagner peut avoir donné des idées peu à
certains autres légers qui peuvent se
voir pousser des ailes et avoir le désir
et bien de mener le le même type
d'aventure alors oui mais plus que ça je
pense évidemment il y a un vrai besoin
mais pourquoi parce que il y a la guerre
en Ukraine et la guerre en Ukraine si
vous voulez c'est sa statut des hommes
et il est très encore une fois l'outil
combattant est nécessaire et l'armée
russe au lit ne peut pas se passer de
l'outil combattant quel qu'il soit
ou soit une armée donc tout ce qui peut
se développer qui renforce la sécurité
c'est bien le deuxième truc enfin le
deuxième point qui est très important
c'est que Poutine est assez satisfaite
tout ça c'est plutôt intéressant
mais qui l'a concrètement aidé qu'il l'a
financé en partie il a il a il considère
enfin Poutine à comment dire accréditer
l'idée selon laquelle il avait dépensé 1
milliard de dollars pour financer Wagner
ce qui nous sommes absolument énorme
donc on voit bien qu'il espèce d'envie
donc en fait les CMP toutes ces tous ces
seigneurs de la guerre parce que c'est
ça qui apparaît aujourd'hui en Russie
ben en fait font plaisir à Poutine en
développant des outils militaires c'est
ce qu'a fait Kaddy Rohff avec les
tchétchène il dit voilà nous moi j'ai
10000 hommes je voulais prête je vous
les donne on est sur un modèle vraiment
moyenâgeux totalement médiéval qui est
incroyable et c'est vrai que les tarus
aujourd'hui perd en substance c'est pour
ça que je suis un goût veut résister
c'est pour ça que l'armée russe elle
résiste parce qu'elle voit bien qu'elle
perd des parts de marché elle perd du
prestige et elle perd des missions on a
parlé de l'Ukraine un autre terrain
également sur largement déployé dans les
années c'est l'Afrique et là aussi c'est
très stratégique pour Moscou comment
vont réagir les dirigeants africains à
la mort de Prigogine est-ce qu'ils vont
forcément appeler Wagner à la rescousse
maintenant que son chef a été décapité
alors c'est encore une fois une très
bonne question pourquoi parce que c'est
vrai que la mort de Prigogine à la fin
du mois d'août a été un ébranlement dans
les dans les systèmes africains
principalement les pays qui avaient fait
appel à eux la RCA enfin africaine le
Mali probablement le Soudan la Libye il
y avait un vrai questionnement sur quel
était la suite et ça ce sont des pays
qui aujourd'hui ne peuvent pas se passer
de la Russie et nid de Wagner d'ailleurs
donc on voit qu'il y a un double
problème c'est que 1 l'État russe en
tant que tel l'administration russe mais
ça la défense et les affaires étrangères
ont été tout de suite ont été en Afrique
et on fait le tour de toute l'Afrique
avec la vraie principalement mais ils
ont été au Soudan ils ont été au Mali
etc d'ailleurs une partie de la colère
de trigogine lorsqu'il était en Afrique
c'est le le reportage que vous avez
montré en introduction c'est très
intéressant c'est qu'il a découvert que
en fait les tarus avait demandé aux
États africains de ne pas favoriser le
déplacement de prix d'origine en Afrique
il a réalisé que son avion il peut pas
se poser non autorisation de se poser ni
même de décoller et donc il était très
en colère et donc il est au lieu de
rester un mois en Afrique ce qu'il
voulait faire il est resté qu'une seule
semaine il est rentré et là il s'est
fait assassiner si vous voulez sur le
transfert entre Moscou et
Saint-Pétersbourg donc on voit bien que
les targues cherche à récupérer la main
mise c'est un outil politique Wagner il
faut pas l'oublier donc encore une fois
les targues a besoin de cet outil
politique qui permet deux choses un
empreinte minimum c'est pas l'armée
russe qui est qui est visible et de ce
qu'on appelle le déni plausible c'est
qu'en fait s'il y a un problème c'est
pas moi si ça marche c'est moi je le
dirai pas et si ça marche pas bah c'est
pas moi donc il faut que c'est
extrêmement intéressant en terme de
visibilité en termes de présence donc si
vous voulez les Targus va aller chercher
à développer sur encore une fois sur les
problématiques que la France peut avoir
dans les pays francophones mais va
développer au travers de structures
comme Wagner et bien évidemment va
chercher à développer toute cette partie
économique et fondamentale puisque ce
n'est pas de marché c'est une présence
politique rappelez-vous encore une fois
la France à l'époque quand on entre
guillemets l'Afrique francophone qui
votait pour nous aux Nations Unis c'est
30 voix garanties aujourd'hui les Russes
cherchent à faire ça aussi et certaines
sociétés militaires privées seraient
déjà en train de recruter pour reprendre
un certain nombre d'activités en Afrique
est-ce qu'elles ont selon vous les mêmes
capacités suffisamment en tout cas de
capacités humaines logistique matériel
est-ce qu'elles auraient les mêmes
intérêts Wagner alors les mêmes intérêts
absolument ça c'est certain ils vont
tous essayer de faire la même chose
encore une fois je pense que les Targus
prend les affaires en main alors il va
ils vont servir de Wagner parce qu'ils
vont pas casser l'outil qui préexiste et
aucune raison qu'il le fasse mais bien
évidemment ils vont créer une
concurrence concrètement c'est l'État
russe qui va gérer mais vous savez déjà
maintenant un RCA aurait pu sont
africaines à Bangui on voit très bien
Wagner a été un outil opérationnel mais
dans les rouages du pouvoir de de
comment dire en plus de centrafricaine
vous aviez déjà des des fonctionnaires
russes qui étaient présents au mystères
de la défense à la présidence à la
primature etc donc si vous voulez cette
espèce d'imbrication cette consanguinité
qui existe entre Wagner et les tarrus
elle existe elle va pas s'arrêter donc
encore une fois on voit bien que les
targues va chercher encore une fois à
contrôler davantage comment dire le
développement de CSMP ça prendra Wagner
s'appellera Morane s'appellera Enoc tout
ce que vous voulez mais on voit bien que
cet outil est devenu absolument
indispensable ou comment dire à
l'influence russe tout simplement